Gary W. Goldstein: Whether I am a screenwriter
or some other form of creative, I think one
of the key disciplines is to understand that
discipline is key.
And that is to say you should find out what
works best for you.
Are you a morning person?
Are you a late night writer?
I’m not creative late at night.
I like being up but I’m not creative…I
write like a fiend when I have that early
morning coffee, because all night it has been
percolating for me (but that’s not true
for everybody).
But if that is who you are, then make damn
certain that you’ve gone to bed at a reasonable
hour and that you’re up and you’ve gotten
your stuff done and now at 6:00 in the morning
or 7:00 in the morning or whatever it is,
you’ve set aside and you’ve turned your
phone off and that you’ve absolutely put
these soundproof walls around you (literally
and figuratively) so that you have two-three
hours of intensely productive time on a consistent
daily basis.
If you do that…because it’s a game of
inches…and if you do that, instead of being
the person who is laboring over a script and
rewriting it for three years non-stop or you’re
doing a lot of first drafts and you are on
your 12th script this year, those are not
the indicators of success.
But if you’re someone who has got that kind
of discipline and you say ‘How much can
I improve this?’
We know that writing is rewriting, but up
to a point.
So how many drafts?
If I can do this every day and then I set
it aside and move onto the next one.
I may come back to that with proper inspiration.
But if you can do that, what you can accomplish
in a short, one-year period will put to shame
most people who don’t have that discipline.
Who don’t know themselves and give themselves
a framework to be productive.